il n'a pas oublié ses copains et non
plus ne longtemps oublié quand on le
voit quoi on dit qu'il a commencé là et
tout s'est bien passé pour nous si on
tape des petits fous de la laisser dans
le champ un malin plaisir moi salut je
me présente c'est un wiltord meilleur
buteur du championnat et pourtant je
suis pas un buteur un passé de la 1re
division de district amateurs à la
division 1 professionnelle en cinq
saisons voici l'histoire merveilleuse de
sylvain wiltord
sylvain est un monde de banlieue issu
d'une famille de huit enfants de la cité
des fauvettes à neuilly sur marne
aujourd'hui trois reines il est deuxième
buteur du club avec moebius à 21 ans il
a conscience d'avoir eu beaucoup de
chance il sait aussi ce qu'il doit à la
banlieue pour la banlieue s'est pas
servi finalement ouais ça m'a servi à
m'endurcir je pars à connaître des
situations les plus difficiles et à les
accepter plus ça m'a servi à prendre
pour la suite couche de là on pense
toujours au copa quoi mais pour se
sortir vaut mieux mettre les copains de
côté puis après les revoir quand on a
réussi